les chercheurs alors est-ce qu'on peut
les découvrir avec les téléspectateurs
qui a démarré à l'est guillaume alors si
vous avez deux passions mon avis votre
épiderme
ouais et montrez vos fesses oui c'est
vrai vous offrir une petite crème
spécialement pour votre fessier non
c'est pareil c'est un gel moussant vous
appliquer tous les jours vous laisser
cinq minutes et alors vous allez avoir
les fesses douce comme du cachemire
c'est vrai mais vraiment pas long mais
c'est que c'est important ça me semble
très important
douze cordes du cash mais on est face à
wayne appliquer tous les jours cinq
minutes je me la pète moi même temps que
moi a déjà déjà le bail et eschau louis
l'émission je suis chez moi et j'en ai
un mais est-ce que vous les voulez que
je fasse
derrière le trou est fait maison où je
vais essayer de suite parce que de faire
tout ça va peut-être passer si j'ai le
plus bitrate au rappeur lil wayne ne
s'était pas mais il ya des caméras
partout hein ah oui mais c'est juste si
on a un vrai régal je vais essayer vous
inquiétez pas je peux vous dire que la
crème cette crème elle doit coûter très
très cher oui ma marque
c'est pas la forêt mais non mais je vous
dis c'est un canot ne fous qui vient de
me faire du mal à d'autres cadeaux bon
bah merci en tout cas merci à eux on a
quoi d'autre alors tiens castaldi vous
aimez la bagarre ouais vous aimez de
donner des claques
oui mais le problème c'est que
maintenant on peut pas parce qu'on doit
être loin avec les deux barrières c'est
vrai donc j'ai trouvé un cadeau pour
vous qui est fantastique c'est la jfp à
distance s'était imposé un bâton et au
bout yens non j'adore ayew mais il
arrive à toi connard mais oui si tu sais
pas en tout cas l'eau un méchoui et
l'achat d'or le poignet ferme intention
police a lâché lâcher ça marche moi je
ne lâche rien
merci pour celle ci était pas d'histoire
de sécurité en cas d'offre engagé le kca
mais c'est pas possible
oui c'est ça ton cadeau c'est ça c'est
ça même cadeau je n'avais pas vu assez
merci en tout cas c'est pas là même qui
sait aller il a dîné mieux quand même si
la douleur pendant le gars du 10 octobre
et cadeaux des faisait un beau cadeau à
l'est alors vous avez aimé la séquence
de la reine je sais que vous aimez lire
eh oui c'est vrai alors du coup je sais
que vous aimez ce qui est doux aussi
ouais je vous ai préparé marais en
peluche votre rien on peut les chiens
très très doux il paraît c'est vrai que
signerait oui c'est vrai c'est vraiment
magique ça j'ai eu deux bons cadeaux un
cadeau de merde
bachaga
merci merci vous avez une très belle ray
et merci merci beaucoup alors la nhtsa
d'or agir a dit oui alors vous êtes un
grand amateur de sport on le sait un
grand pratiquant aussi tout ce que vous
touchez c'est formidable de la boxe ap
temps dont je suis nul mais un sport que
vous aimez aussi particulièrement c'est
le sport automobile
ah ouais on avait un super gars si web
autorise j'adore courte et bagnols et
tout ça est donc j'ai trouvé un sublime
livre pour vous non ouais quand un
bouquin l'autoroute du millionnaire
j'adore les faits pour vous des deux
chevaux de tous du mal et on s'est tous
la voie express vers la richesse pour
devenir riche en fait peut-être où il
avait déjà lu parce que visiblement
voilà mai
on n'a pas aimé lire et regarder s'est
bonifié grâce à sony qui va
littéralement changé votre vie et vous
comprendrez comment vous sentir riche
dès à présent même sans enjeu
merci bas voyez comme une vague j'aime
bien j'aime bien ce cadeau bravo
géraldine merci françois les cadeaux
j'aime bien par castaldi primes etc a
pas beaucoup bossé un sort encore là
nikov qu'estime à mon frère je crois que
vous avez une excellente mais moi oui
c'est vrai si je vous dis 5 mars 2010 5
mars à 2010 c'est sentimental 1 comme
cadeau 07/06/2010 à je pense que c'est
notre réunion qu'on a fait pour préparer
peut-être touche pas à mon poste est ce
que c'est ça alors regardez ce que je
suis arrivé à retrouver comme un masque
c'est ça regardez où la voilà c'est bon
c'est ça c'est votre lettre d'engagement
à france télévisions exactement en
signant par tous les deux non c'est
incroyable ce qu'ils attendent à cacher
les budgets relation à cacher les
budgets bah oui vous avez bien fait
surtout et ses bois sacré bon engagement
si réd émotions tout soit mon poste avec
si les lamas nicolas pernikoff à trouver
parce qu'il a fallu à chercher quand
même ça m'a fait non mais c'est
incroyable j'ai franchement les mecs
mais pour combien gagnez vous dire je
veux dire on avait signé pau 12 x 52
minutes environ 12 et 12 numéros de
touche pas à mon poste avec 52 minutes
et après 52 minutes 52 minutes sur ses
habits tour merci nicolas
merci hugo d'amours qu'eugène merci ma
chérie merci merci beaucoup
kelly alors on à guillaume qui a pensé
un petit peu à prendre soin de vous au
niveau de la beauté il vaut plus
oui au niveau fessiers votre épiderme et
cetera et puis moi je me suis dit que en
ce moment vous aviez énormément de
tension en vous dans votre profond
intérieur puisque à l'intérieur de votre
corps et vous sentir mieux un peu plus
elle avait pris rendez vous chez
proctologue ça je vous ai préparé une
gentil camomille j'ai un coffret en loge
tour vaut alors là buvait pas allées
froides
c'est simple cadeau ouais c'est dingue
c'est important pour se détendre et bah
merci ben voilà c'est pas voilà c'est un
choc à dos et un cadeau à l'affairé
bernard gauthier alors moi je suis
timide et j'aime bien écrire des mots
gens que j'aime
je vous demanderais ça vous ennuie pas
de le lire vous même avec plaisir non
écrit deux lettres
ouais team au bout mais certains voient
un petit bon ouais m'enfin les amis
témoigne musique lisez-le d'abord avant
de dire chose amours la musique
alizée le pdb trichet pas cher cyril
[Musique]
talent succès charisme en effet nous
avons ces trois points en commun nous
avons toujours fait nous avons toujours
su faire les bons choix
la preuve c'est que je suis la chaire
cyril il y a quelque chose de magnifique
dans vos yeux
ça s'appelle mon reflet si certains
disent que vous vous la raconter
donnez-leur raison et dites leur que
vous me connaissez celle oui oui surtout
un dernier conseil
restés droits dans vos bottes comme moi
ne sucent et jamais personne amitié ta
mère enceinte d hanouna bernard montiel
[Applaudissements]
quand on me ruzic
est ce qu'elle peut ne pas être coupés
émettent un truc mais ou pas mais c'est
pas possible quelle bombe pourquoi alors
isabelle tchèque
alors puisque guillaume et delphine se
sont occupés de votre rêve avec moi
j'avais échos bernard a fait un mois il
me restait pas grand chose sont pas mes
donc vous savez non non mais vous avez
raison comme vous ne pensez jamais à moi
c'est meilleur moyen de penser que vous
pensez à moi c'était de vous rappeler
que rtl existe un week-end qu'elle est
en tête sur plusieurs quarts d'heure que
vous étiez que vous y reviendrez à
quelque titre que ce soit et donc pour
que vous pensiez et rtl et à moi je me
devais de nous offrir en attendant le
reste
[Musique]
mais je vais vous dire la vérité et je
peux le dire ce soir rtl pour moi et je
préfère mille fois rtl à france inter
j'adore rtl et rtl on préfère non mais
je vous le dis france inter j'ai je n'ai
jamais écouté manu m6 est la première de
france je sais pas comment ils sont
première à d'autres ans mais en tout cas
ils y sont je pensais pas ce cas pas de
pub ci avait pas de pub sur rtl il
serait largement premier voilà mes rtl
veut gagner de l'argent parce qu'ils
n'ont pas le service public pour leur
donner de l'argent
salut mais voilà c'est pas beau ce que
john deere à ses manies mois il vous est
pas un cadeau soit mais oui c'est vrai
oui parce que quand j'entends les talons
sur france inter
franchement je me dis j'espère qu'à
l'étranger quand ils écoutent et qui se
dit c'est ça la première heure de france
je peux vous dire ils doivent se dire hé
ben ammar et ben quand même se dire la
france suit 1 c'est vraiment un pays en
voie de développement
non mais j'ai voulu faire quelque chose
de personnel
et vous savez que je vous aime j'ai mis
à les quitter l'émission j'ai mis toute
mon âme et serait faux tout mon corps et
je vais faire une petite vidéo pour vous
montrer pour ça non regardons
[Musique]
c'est magnifique il armait et leurs
maîtres
alors m excusez-moi année hors agatha
s'est très mal produits haute couture
mais je sais pas ouais vachement bien
fait ça uniquement on est non mais
arrêtez uniquement au niveau des petits
ça oui vous avez du pif a franchement
c'est pas mal sans rigoler mais tu as
mis ton des plus beaux portraits que
vous avez c'est vrai franchement c'est
sur le plot semblons voici merci
d'envoyer ou pas elle va merci gilles
verdez merci pour vos cadeaux
ouais c'est la sincérité mais fait des
très très beau cadeau pour moi le plus
beau cadeau
je vous tiens là deux c'est l'arrêt non
c'est nicolas bien sûr le contrat est
bien entendu c'est quand même la crème
pour les fesses sa percée ça ça va me
servir
merci à vous les